il préfère un rendez vous que vous
attendez bien sûr avec impatience il
s'agit de watou battre voilà pour notre
sommaire et je vous dit alors que nous
avons placé cette émission sur le thème
des sports de plein air les sports que
vous pouvez pratiquer facilement et sans
trop grands frais par exemple du patin
vous fait du patin à roulettes c'est
très facile et surtout avec le nouveau
pataky - france et vous verrez c'est
très facile
il ya également un sport que vous
connaissez peut-être pas très bien il
s'agit de la marche pas n'importe quelle
marche mais la marche sportive un ami
vedra nous en parler et un autre sport
qui là est peut-être réserver aux plus
grands il s'agit du delta l' aile delta
nous en verrons donc un film d'ailleurs
son saut sport très joli et ah oui
j'allais oublier de vous dire
au cours de cette émission un grand
critérium une première dans récré a2 en
effet un grand concours vélo alors là ne
manquez pas ce rendez vous mais puisque
c'est une émission sportive n'est ce pas
je n'ai pas voulu être en reste
je prends mes accessoires non non ce
n'est pas du ski attention je vais tout
mon avc place sur le plateau et je
commence à me prendre la ville
on me disais que j'étais sportif voilà